fiona's like fairy godmother
is like sort of preying on her family
and she's trying to force a marriage
between her son and fiona so she's like
trying to get shrek out and so
there's like this potion and dude they
slip it into fiona's drink which is
crazy and then
it's like if she kisses someone before
midnight she'll fall in love with that
person and then her the fairy godmother
son just straight up runs up to fiona
and just [ __ ] just sexually assaults
her in a way that just [ __ ] kisses
her on the mouth and they know that they
slipped the [ __ ] in her drink that's the
dark yeah i was like bro what she's
gonna fall in love with him forever like
that's dark it's more than a kiss jesus
christ i wouldn't say that's an adult
theme i would say that
that's just [ __ ] up why did you guys
decide to watch shrek 2. we ran shrek 1
in the background while we ate some
pizza i think someone was like elena was
like prawn strike 2 and i said why
we were asked the first one it's just
going to be because it's the sequel
yeah i know but i didn't i thought it
was just going to be like one but just
you know another feel good like who
cares and then cash was like urging he's
like no no dude put on shrek 2. it's a
it's a it's a surprisingly funny movie
let me put it on and all and just things
are happening i'm like holy [ __ ]
this is crazy it made me want to watch
it again is there a shrek 3
there is but it doesn't even matter i
understand now all the inspiration for
all those like shrek his love cartoons
and stuff and i even get all the like
you know the the pseudo like or like all
the shrek porn that you see on twitter
i don't
i don't follow those they're just good
reply memes you know
yeah yeah i know what you're saying like
you you shut the [ __ ] up you know what
i'm talking about i've seen some good
shows you've seen the naked fiona dude
you've seen the naked fiona you have
what no
i'm just saying if you watch shrek 2 and
like i don't know maybe slightly
inebriated whatever just like slightly
like a little [ __ ] up when you watch
track 2 it's just like you you're like
oh man this is this is kind of
some of this [ __ ] is kind of heavy